and marco gonzalez
on the mound for the seattle mariners
here are his starting pitcher stats
brought to you by
home furniture a little scouting report
likes to pitch inside with his fastball
you wouldn't think so at 88 miles an
hour
and polanco drives on to right center
field that's down for a hit polanco
rounding first he'll hold up there with
the settle a single for second and home
run so they want to hit the ball out of
the ballpark
there is the curve ball from marco
gonzalez
stroke to left and that'll die in front
of the left fielder chad long
and polanco goes to second on the end of
the bat single and learning batting
cleanup
and larnick drives one to right center
field down for a hit palaco around third
being waved in and the twins with three
singles score the first run in the first
larnick driving in his ninth run
2-1 to jeffers
france at first base
onto the warning track and toss
you know sometimes uh a little too far
in front but he's able to reach back and
make the catch
three pitches all strikes he expands on
ceno and gets his second punch out and
strands a couple marco limits to damage
one-nothing twins
[Music]
and the starting pitchers stats brought
to you by home furniture for their
return to the rotation of kenta maeda
and
for maeda it is just
all about location
dropped it on a perfect spot
and the command
has
not been there this year at least not
the command we saw
from maida last year but that's a pretty
good first at bat there
braley taking off and it's ball four
consecutive walks you can see maeda's
face he's not pleased
the streak has come to a close from aida
he has walked three straight three of
the first four batters in fact
give him some momentum to come back and
have a good interview
best change-up of the inning
was a
beautiful pitch that struck out bowers
as they leave the bases full
an mvp before being injured i watched
him take bp today it was pretty good
marco makes quick work to celestino and
he retires the side in order
like chicago for all the obvious reasons
yeah strikeout of murphy back to back
strikeouts now for maeda and three so
far in the game
crabs
there's a food theme developing here
well
what else is there to do
nice change up down and away third
straight swinging strikeout
for miata
first time through the order maid has
issued three walks but struck out five
including four in a row
soft fly ball into right field now
bowers is making only his sixth career
start in right field
play the outfield plenty but mostly in
left mixing it up a little bit
slug got to left this turns shed around
he's able to gallop back and haul it in
you know you're not going to be picky
yeah that's a good that's always a good
thing
that ball hit hard to center field back
is tremel looking up it's hard off the
wall crews rounding second he'll gain
third base and that was one trevor will
be proud of
he likes he likes them all he likes that
one better
marco's 1-2
he got him swinging at the hook and
marco leaves him loaded strikes out
cenote for the second time
and steps fraley who walked earlier
how about this fillet into shadow left
center jp crawford is steaming home jake
fraley continues to drive in runs he's
on base for the second time already and
has tied this game at one
breaking ball in a good spot another
strikeout
six strikeouts for maeda
and polanco
to end the threat one for the mariners
two left aboard
and it's one apiece
[Applause]
right fielder alex gorilla off will lead
things off of one is grounded out to
short
kerala drives it to center hit well
tremel going back at the wall it's gone
alex carol off with his fifth and the
twins are back in front that's
impressive bring up celestino
celestino drives one deep to left down
the line and gone
his first big league home run and run
batted in
and the twins take a three to one lead
pitch near the corner and i like i like
that a lot three pitches
three strikes
two away
skimming out there to second base
stealing more
he's got it and the double is stranded
[Applause]
one on one on ty france now batting
that's a hard hit ground ball inside the
bag at third
braley is motoring into third base
manny's waving him home
jake fraley scores standing tight france
rbi doubled it's a one-run game that'll
bring up second baseman dylan moore
to center
driven
and off the wall
celestino as well
this game is tied as dylan moore
stands up at third base
one two
he got him swinging slider pinned on the
lower inside corner
[Applause]
fly ball very high out to left
shed says he's got it and he makes the
catch a couple of men are left stranded
jaguar goes two innings for just the
second time this season and keeps it
tied as we stretch
the knees strike three
lead off single but duffy faces just
three men on the seventh
how about the payoff
reaching for a pitch off the plate a
slow dribbler dylan moore a little
overhand pass to first base
and time to get a rise and the time run
is stranded aboard to the bottom of the
eighth all time
here is bowers with one out
slogged out to center field gordon can't
make the catch and it is over the wall
and a home
run jake bowers first in the mariners
uniform gives the mariners the lead in
the bottom of the eighth it comes down
to nelson cruz
hard hit ground ball crawford has it
deep in the hole takes his time and the
mariners win